Very old.
I grew up listening to these songs.
My family would play these songs to me when I was a little girl and make me sing them.
I love hearing Arabic melodies on Western music.
And now, I can walk around comfortably as an Arab in Britain...
...because people can celebrate the culture with me.
For me, it's great that it's embedded here in Britain.
Taking it back to when I was younger, going to school, growing up and going to college,...
...when I was living in Britain, I used to feel very British.
Now, I feel very Palestinian.
But, in terms of how I think, I think the open-mindedness has definitely come from Britain.
It definitely comes from growing up here,...
...and that's, I think,  that's how British I feel.
I've been given the privilege of knowing what freedom feels like, being here.
I have the option of choosing what path I want to go down and that's part of the journey.
And I've taken that with me.
Well, actually no, it's taken me with it through music.
When I started rapping in Arabic, it started off as a hobby.
I wasn't uncomfortable with singing, like rapping in English or singing in English,...
...but I felt like I really had to, I had to be honest and real with myself and original.
I wanted to claim a voice.
I wanted to claim an identity in terms of being a Palestinian and the diaspora.
When I went and actually performed the songs live in Palestine, in front of a live audience,...
...it was an amazing experience, going there...
...and seeing the people that listen to my music face to face...
...and trying to keep their identity and maintain it.
It's like taking the songs home.
Actually, going to Palestine really made me appreciate the privileges we have here.
You actually have a chance here to have your voice heard.
I value the freedom of speech in Britain.
And I've started to appreciate that, whereas before I didn't actually notice it.
I didn't realize it.
So I do feel like that's been kind of a backbone for me.
I'd have to say definitely that British society and Britain as a whole has been kind of like a backbone.
It's shaped my ability to be able to do what I do with no restrictions.